what would a city look like without a
government
imagine not lawless anarchy there's
still a government federal state what
have you just not its own government
there would be no planning no zoning no
mayor and no public infrastructure
you might think it's a silly question
who in their right mind would live there
after all
but imagine for some reason this city is
the size of phoenix or philadelphia home
to about 1.5 million people
without government who would make the
trains run on time or even make sure
there was a train in the first place
who would inspect buildings for safety
or test the purity of water
you don't actually need to imagine there
is such a place
it's called kurgao
india's privately owned city
because there were no public roads water
pipes energy lines or fire stations
corporations simply built their own
sponsored by curiosity stream and nebula
get both for just 15 bucks a year
why would anyone much less a million and
a half people
move to a place with no central sewage
or water system
while gurgaon may not be home to any
natural resources to speak of it does
have one big thing going for it
proximity
it's about a half hour drive southwest
of delhi india's capital and the second
largest city on earth
instead of slowly sprawling outward into
suburbs construction in delhi was all of
the sudden forced to relocate
in 1957 the delhi development act banned
private real estate developers leaving
them with no choice but to move
elsewhere
the reason that elsewhere became gurgao
was a man named sanjay gandhi
sanjay dreamt of an indian made
automobile an aspirational pride of the
nation the government at the time argued
its focus should be on mass transit not
wasteful personal cars but sanjay was
the son of india's prime minister and
his wish therefore became command
gurgaon was chosen for the factory
precisely because the land was worthless
rural undeveloped and rather unimportant
his car turned out to be a total failure
but was eventually bought by suzuki who
by the early 80s employed 20 000 workers
in the then small town
land laws are complicated in india
owners must apply for permits which
can't be transferred to new owners and
the whole process involves many layers
of bureaucracy
not to mention rampant corruption
because of this gurgao may have remained
a small industrial outpost forever
except for a lucky coincidence
nearly all of its land was under the
jurisdiction of just one single office
of course this one was no more immune to
corruption than any other office but
there was a critical difference
say for example a company wants to
develop a plot of land to do so it needs
a permit
the agency responsible can therefore
demand a bribe if it believes the land
will generate one million dollars in
profit in theory it can ask as much as
999 000
and the developer will agree still
making a profit
but if the permit requires the approval
of two agencies each will try to extract
the maximum value possible for a
combined two million dollars twice the
actual value leaving the company with no
incentive
thus unless all parties coordinate
perfectly the land will sit empty and
its economic potential will be wasted
corcao in other words was no economic
utopia bribes were common but the lack
of red tape made paying them quick and
easy
that made all the difference soon
companies like nestle coca-cola dell and
american express flocked to the city's
cheap labor proximity to delhi and an
international airport and lack of
bureaucracy
and with them came a wave of skilled
middle class knowledge workers and
expats
delhi was old crowded dirty but in
corgao developers introduced luxury
estates walled off high rises with a
shared pool clubhouse and shopping mall
there was just one tiny problem
there was still no real government
that meant no public transit road sewage
electric grid water you name it
still to this day many roads simply
don't have names including one outside
its civil hospital which surely makes
getting there a bit tricky in an
emergency
and so to induce demand developers
simply created supply
whatever customers demanded they
provided
its rapid metro is the world's first 100
privately owned modern light metro
system
to pay the bills each station is
auctioned off to the highest corporate
bidder who becomes its sponsor
you might meet your friend at vodafone
belvedere tower station paid for by the
british telecommunications company
vodafone it's even painted vodafone red
two-thirds of the city's population
aren't connected to the main sewage line
while they may flush their toilets
without knowing it their pipes end in a
septic tank at the edge of the property
waiting to be dumped just outside the
estate walls
electricity may be erratic but those on
the 30th floor don't know the difference
their power is backed up by privately
owned diesel power generators
the public employ just 4 000 police
officers while developers maintain a
legion of 35 000 security
the city's fire preparation is equally
comical in 2008 there were just 14
public fire engines despite the central
government mandating no fewer than 42
for a city of its size
worse their pumps could only spray up to
40 meters
the tallest building is 300.
real estate companies had no choice but
to build their own fire stations which
act as a quasi public service in times
of emergency helping anyone in need
its business hub cyber city boasts
having weapon mounted scorpio suvs a
security force of 500 and 8 000 security
cameras
now on paper all of this development was
part of a public-private partnership
private companies would build their own
infrastructure and the city would
connect it all
but of course without any system of
enforcement or an explicit contract
developers built only what their
customers demanded and nothing more
despite being the third largest source
of tax revenue to the central indian
government somehow a formal municipal
body was only created in 2008 by which
time it was already home to over a
million people
even then its power is extremely limited
about the only thing it did was rename
the city though few noticed
if gurgaon is an accidental experiment
in what happens when corporations are
left to fill the role of government what
are the results
the answer depends on who you are
its privately owned islands rival any of
the world's great cities and cleanliness
and comfort
tiger woods once played around at the
arnold palmer designed dlf golf and
country club
the fortis memorial hospital draws
people from all around and its high
rises offer every luxury under the sun
but step outside these artificial
islands even just an inch and everything
changes
untreated sewage is dumped straight into
the river electricity is sporadic the
air is polluted extreme flooding is not
uncommon and traffic jams are a daily
fact of life
in 2016 thousands of cars were stuck on
the road during a flood which canceled
school for two whole days
at one point traffic got so bad that a
judge ordered the paws of toll
collection to speed things up
so what is gurgaon
a brutal lived lesson on the limits of
capitalism
or an extraordinary example in the
lengths the free market will go to fill
in the gaps all on its own
in short
yes
this on the other hand is a city that
doesn't actually exist but one with just
as powerful a lesson
the unknown city is a video which
completely blew me away it's a stunning
3d rendered journey by neo exclusively
available on nebula the streaming
platform that as i'm sure you know by
now was built by and for creators
roughly every other polymatter video has
bonus or extended content on nebula like
this one about how corporations vote in
hong kong or this one about the upcoming
beijing olympics
get access to great documentaries on
curiosity stream like this one which
journeys through the world's most
dangerous road in india and nebula by
signing up with a link in the
description for just 15 bucks a year not
a month but a year